can i pick up first of all if i may
please with what we're hearing from the
foreign the home secretary forgive me
this morning saying more than doubling
the number of interpreters their
families and ancillary staff that will
be able to come to the uk you must
welcome that
yes i mean i think we've got a moral
obligation to those afghans who helped
us help their country um so i think it's
right and proper that we should do what
we can for them ten thousand enough i
don't know i mean i think those are
often going to be political judgments
and of course a lot of it will depend
upon the feasibility of who can travel
and that the pace at which they can
travel what are you hearing about what's
happening on the ground well at the
moment i think it's very calm i think we
are collaborating with the taliban on
the ground
um and that seems to be a very
straightforward relationship they are
keeping the streets of kabul very st
very safe and indeed very calm they are
helping us at the airport um i think we
have a worrying problem potentially with
worried afghans
trying to get into the airport again we
saw some very troubling scenes over the
weekend but providing we can keep
control around the airport perimeter
there's no reason to suppose that we
can't carry on doing what we're doing
there may always be the threat from
renegade elements of the taliban you
know it's not a homogeneous organization
it may not have control over all of its
people but at the moment uh they're
controlling things very effectively and
they're allowing us to do what we need
to do helping you in what way in an
appropriate way that we would find
acceptable yes absolutely in what way um
so they're keeping the streets um calm
they're avoiding public disorder they're
going to be quite thuggish at some of
those checkpoints firing over people's
heads and the like well i think they've
also got challenges with public order
but certainly what we're not getting are
reports of um the behaving in a sort of
medieval way like you might have seen in
the past now it has to temper all of
this one has to be very careful but some
of the public pronouncements that we're
hearing from the political commission
and indeed they are now in kabul and
they are forming a government and they
are talking to president karzai who i've
talked to regularly over the weekend
and president karzai and dr abdullah
will meet with them today
and there's no reason to suppose that
they can't come to a sensible solution
for how an inclusive government can run
the country in the future recognizing
that there of course will always be
elements who may not behave as we would
hope they would behave there will be a
finite time before they want their
airport back does that mean that
inevitably we will have to leave some
people behind
um i don't know yet uh i think what we
have to do is your fear i think we have
to take each day as it comes um and we
have to see how it happens i mean the
political commission have made it pretty
clear that those afghans who want to
leave afghanistan they'll let leave
afghanistan so let's see how it happens
i don't think they want to become
international perez again they want to
have a functioning airport they want to
have diplomatic missions inside kabul
that they can talk to they also
recognize that they need humanitarian
support so the important thing at the
moment is to maintain engagement with
them and to make sure that we don't
close out on anything
but your your boss the defense secretary
was moved to tears uh earlier in the
week you know is very well documented um
saying that he feels that we will
inevitably have to leave people behind
we don't know yet um how that will
happen at the moment it is all running
smoothly and let's see what the taliban
allow us all to do at the moment um
we're going to continue
we're going to continue to move as many
people as we possibly can given the
circumstances we've got and yes of
course you know we are having to
collaborate with them um they now
provide uh the security on the ground in
kabul uh and we are gonna work with them
in order to be able to conduct the
evacuation that is now underway and how
do you feel about collaborating with the
enemy when um they have carried out such
atrocities against um uk military
personnel over the years i think you
have to be very careful using the word
enemy um i think people need to
understand who the taliban actually are
and of course what they are a disparate
collection of tribes people as president
karzai put it to me only yesterday
they're country boys
and the plain fact is that they happen
to live by a code of honour and a
standard which has been their standard
for many many years it's called pashtun
wally it has honour at the heart of what
they do they are bound together by a
common purpose which is they don't like
corrupt governance they don't like
governance that is self-serving and they
want an afghanistan that is inclusive
for all so i think rather than talking
about them what except women
well again i think we have to wait and
see i mean i don't know what they mean
we can't support the way that they treat
women surely well i think you have to
listen to what they're saying at the
moment and i think you have to listen to
the facts on the ground they're saying
they are definitely back
yeah and i'm not saying that's anything
that you and i would approve of
particularly but i do find that
absolutely but i do think that they have
changed i think they recognize that over
the course the last 20 years afghanistan
has evolved they recognize the
fundamental role that women have played
in that evolution and yes they at the
moment will undoubtedly say that they
want to respect women's rights under
islamic law and that will be a sharia
law but that doesn't necessarily mean
that they won't allow them to be
involved in government and in education
and in medicine and those things that
they need them to be involved in so i
think we have to be patient we have to
give them the space to show how they are
going to step up to the plate and
whether or not we can work with them
will very much depend upon how they
treat all afghans
some of your former colleagues rory
stewart johnny mercer all men that have
served tom tugan hearts said we
shouldn't believe a word that the
taliban says and and more than that we
saw women demons very brave women
demonstrating on the streets in kabul
yesterday saying
we don't want the taliban here and and i
respect all of that all i'm simply
saying is that let's see how this
evolves because it may well be that
we're surprised by it yes we should do
it very carefully yes we should be
fundamentally suspicious because of
course we know where they came from and
we've also seen behavior by different
elements of the taliban which we
absolutely wouldn't condone and indeed
it has been brutal in many ways in other
parts of afghanistan but we should give
them the space at the moment to
demonstrate whether or not they're going
to govern differently okay so
what does that space look like how long
do we need to wait to see whether
they've changed how many women need to
be raped how many uh girls need to be
married off at the age of 12 how many
women need to be told that they can't be
educated past the university level um
none of that is appropriate of course
it's all that would be beyond the pale
but i think again i would ask you to
show the evidence where that's happening
in kabul at the moment
yeah what my question is is how long do
we need to wait how many women need to
be raped or murdered or beaten they go
out i come back i come back to you
show us the evidence of that actually
happening on the ground at the moment so
how many is acceptable one no none is
accepted okay just to clarify on that
let me ask you about an article that you
wrote in the times i'm sure you've been
asked about it already this morning on
the 5th of august um
10 just over 10 days ago saying that it
was too soon
to write off the afghan security forces
um i think that you have to go back a
bit first of all we need to be very
clear that the afghan security forces
fought very bravely from 2014 when they
effectively took over the combat
operations in afghanistan until this
year i think you also need to recognize
that come the fourth of july they lost
all of their american support that
they'd become accustomed to and
particularly they lost the air power now
that was a very shattering moment in
terms of their morale and we as military
people talk about fighting power as to
how an army fights or armed forces fight
and of course that's about the
conceptual the physical and
fundamentally about the moral and of
course i think what happened from the
fourth of july onwards was their morale
was shattered and of course they were up
against an opponent who was very able in
the information warfare space and was
able very fundamentally to demonstrate
that it had the momentum and i think
that
as a consequence of all of that it
collapsed and we've seen that many times
in history you know if you look back to
1942 the way our army is particularly if
we may i mean you're talking about the
4th of july you wrote this just 10 days
ago saying that we shouldn't write them
off is that because our intelligence let
us down no not at all what i was saying
was absolutely to try and support them
in their fight because if we all talked
them down that of course would undermine
their morale and fundamentally what we
needed to be doing was to try and make
them feel confident to try and make them
feel unified and to try and make them
fight for what they believed in look how
that worked out indeed but you know at
the end of the day we had to talk about
that to give them the confidence to do
that if we had been talking about
running them down about how useless they
were and how they couldn't fight then
obviously that would have brought it on
even quicker than what occurred what we
needed to be doing at the time was
trying to give them the confidence to be
able to rely on a pep talk to try to
save on the contrary morale is about
leadership morale is about giving people
confidence to fight
why did they why did they not believe in
that confidence from arson from the
united states well what i'm saying is
that they of course were led by their
own chain of command and clearly that
chain of command as we now know broke
down they didn't believe in that chain
of command they were up against a very
effective opponent who had the momentum
behind them and of course when you are
living in the country and your families
are living in the country you know
unless you hold together fearful of
course
and i think
what the cohesion possibility to go back
now to try to support them and to look
after these people who relied on us
sorry i missed the first path question
part of my question i'm sorry interrupt
we're almost out of time is to say
does an allied force need to return to
afghanistan at some stage in some
numbers
not necessarily let's hold on earth
let's be patient let's see how things
evolve and let's recognize that if of
course the threat from terrorism
re-emerges in afghanistan then we may
have to think again but at the moment
let's hold our nerve and what about
those soldiers of many i've spoken to
over the last few days
who say the last two decades was in vain
look not a day goes by when i don't
think of the people who died under my
command in afghanistan not a day goes by
when i don't think about those afghans
who've worked alongside me to try and
make their country a better place that's
what i think about and of course i
sympathize i empathize with everybody
who's lived and fought in afghanistan
over the last 20 years
and i think we have done a lot to
improve afghanistan and i think we can
hold our heads up high as military
people for what we've done on the ground
because we've never been defeated
tactically on the ground and we have
fought and died alongside each other and
we've done it in a thoroughly brave
fashion but half the population of
afghanistan is below the age of 18 we
shouldn't rule out going back to support
those people if necessary perhaps not
but those are decisions that we need to
take at a much higher level than me all
i'm simply saying pretty high levels no
i don't think so because those are
political decisions i'm
the head of the military and i provide
military advice those are political
judgments the bottom line is that what
is more interesting i think about the
over 50 of afghans who are under 18 is
of course they've never lived under the
taliban and what will be interesting is
whether or not the taliban respect the
fact that those
are essentially the future of their
country and they want to live in a
different way and that's where i think
we have to give the people of
afghanistan hope and if they don't
let's see what happens let's see what
happens bottom line there's a lot of
waiting to see isn't there well of
course there is you know come on you
know
things are unfolding incredibly quickly
nobody could have predicted quite what's
happened now
it's very easy to be wise with the
benefit of hindsight which is why it is
important to be steady to hold your
nerve to provide a bit of patience to
stay engaged and to be prepared okay
it's good to talk to you thank you for
taking the time to join us it's always a
pleasure thank you